we begin today in southern california  and new details about that deadly  shooting in orange that happened last  night at a business park  investigators now say the alleged gunman  knew the four victims he  shot and killed he also locked the gates  of the complex before he opened fire  allegedly  the victims have not been identified but  do include a nine-year-old boy  one other victim was hurt and taken to  the hospital the gunman was found  wounded  and taken into custody the suspect has  been identified as 44 year old  amenadab gaxiola gonzalez  with a last known address in fullerton  it is a horrible horrible tragedy  that mr gonzalez made a decision to use  deadly force  to deal with issues he was dealing with  apparently in his life  but he will suffer and face the  consequences  police say this was the city's deadliest  shooting since 1997.